we are back live.
Hi.
I'm a bit late today.
Yeah, it turns out uh
running a 10K six days a week and
lifting on a cut uh is kind of tiring.
So, I slept in a bunch. Did my normal
routine and I'm here now.
I slept like an hour or whatever. Not
that bad. Anyways though,
what I'd like to figure out is the best
way to get world model stuff working
today.
This is the original
world model paper, right?
So why?
Oh, so this is intentionally low
dimensional
latent vector.
I see.
Does this work without decoder?
Original world models. Paper spirit.
Oh.
Good afternoon. I guess it is afternoon.
I'm super late today.
funny that it is a um
we can use the VAE to reconstruct each
frame ZT.
I guess these are all sample based,
right?
And then they use I mean they use
genetic algs instead of RL on this
because uh David H likes genetic algs
not because it actually works better. I
guarantee you.
Interesting that the world model is so
much bigger.
There are ablations on this.
encoder just reduces the ob size. That's
not necessarily the point. The point is
that it puts it into um
like you can't just use the
observations, right? You need to encode
them because otherwise you would need to
predict. Well, I guess technically you
could do it this way for pixels, but uh
when you roll out the world model
several steps, you don't actually have
the observations
after the first step, right? You have to
predict some latent.
This is like a super schmid huber.
You'll see this, you immediately know.
Oh yeah, Schmidt Huber.
So, do we need a sample base thing to
make this work like at all? Do we need
like a big world model as well to make
this work at all?
Well, hang on.
But wait, you have
actually the encoder is not necessarily
big because it needs to be big in
general. It's big because these are
images.
Okay. So like let's say that we assume
I mean, the goal for today is really
just to like
get some sort of world model formulation
that actually does stuff.
So, first of all, I did this towards the
end of yesterday. Let's see if what I
was doing made any bloody sense at all.
might be the case I have to take a break
from this today and do um environment
dev. We'll see. But I'm going to at
least start on this.
Why are you posting the reream message
something?
I think I just kind of confused myself
with how I have this. And this is
probably like not doing what I think
it's doing. Right.
Hang on. This produces from zred
get action. So this part's correct
state.
Okay.
Then you have Z
which is
Sure.
Hey, how are you today? That is it
cutting your messages off and doing that
automatically or are you like trolling
and posting the reream message?
I'm a bit tired, but I'm all right.
I've got a uh
pretty heavy
training regimen
uh for a few weeks here.
How's the implementation going? Hi
Satcha. I'm um
working on No, I'm trolling. Sorry.
Yeah, I figured.
How's the implementation going? Um,
we have something that kind of looks
like a world model, but it's not really
it's not really training how we would
want it to yet.
This doesn't train at all right now.
Right.
Make sure
I'm trying to think Satcha. Do you know
like what's the simplest thing that I
should expect to kind of work?
Like why are all these different things
sampling based? Why is everything like
why is the original world model of VAE?
Why is uh the RSSM
uh like why like why is everything
sampling based? Why don't you ever just
have deterministic world model?
Big challenge.
Well, I mean, it's just the fact that
like, you know, the normal state of how
these things are implemented in
research. It's always the jankiest thing
ever.
It's never the case that it's just like,
ah, there's a clever idea. I implement
the clever idea and now it works and
everything is great.
environment has stocastic dynamics just
deterministic part won't work. Right.
Um
You have ideal date of some n
limited. You wanted to teach RL based on
that. What would you do?
one step back. Yeah.
M0 that was initially for only
deterministic dynamic.
It's fine. Like then that shouldn't
matter if I just run this on breakout,
right?
You train the model on it first. Let RL
generalize it. Well, the thing is if
you're saying you have limited data, you
haven't told me how much interaction
you're able to do with the environment,
right?
because like you can't do any RL if you
don't have interaction data with the if
you can't interact with the environment
that's what I figure Satcha um does this
make sense to you if I like
I'm thinking should I just like combine
it with RL
like
I could set this up so that what you do
is you collect your fresh data, you do
standard on policy RL, then you take
some steps on the world model
and then you
uh do some RL on the world model. Like I
could set it up that way
all these architectures that are used in
world models are non-deterministic in
some way. Like a VAE, the way that this
works is you split the hidden uh the
output of a VAE into two bits and then
half of it is the mean and half of it is
variance or standard deviation and then
you sample from it as a distribution.
Like the output of a VAE is a
distribution. And it's not just like a
hidden state or rather you treat the
hidden state that's output like a
distribution
as the main thing.
Stop using sampling bays. I don't mean
stop using them. I'm just wondering like
should it work on a deterministic
environment without it?
Yeah. So, this is Yeah, that makes a
difference.
Variance find bad optima. Nope. Never
ever think about bad optima like that.
It's like a big nerd snipe.
It's like the equivalent of saying bad
humors or whatever in medicine.
dino world mod.
Um,
that can work.
But we're not going to like there's no
point in me doing like tabular methods,
right?
I mean, I need something that I can like
transition into the more complex method.
And there are a whole bunch of things
that would be a problem if I just do
this.
I mean, you're basically doing that,
right, with
like you're not actually really
simplifying much.
Like, unless I try to do something
without using the base setup of puffer,
but like if I'm not using the base setup
of puffer, then like you literally don't
know if a thing should even work like at
all.
Hey, FBR,
welcome.
So
I do Zpre here.
want to hang on. What are you linking me
here?
anytime anybody brings up the no free
lunch theorem, I always just assume that
they're a [ __ ]
Like, I've never I don't think I've ever
heard this being brought up
intelligently in a conversation ever.
I mean that's just claiming like
you know
original Dina as all world models or
whatever.
I would say that like the
the better paper that I would look to as
the classic one is David Haw paper
because this was like the first one that
actually made them work in a convincing
way.
And did I just train this model portion
wrong?
I think I'm just doing the uh the
dynamics prediction wrong somehow.
supposed to be two different things,
right?
Turns are normalized, not advantages.
Um,
generally not normalizing advantages
usually screws you. Hey Marcel, how's
your impressions of
RLC?
RLC was fine. I got to chat with a bunch
of colleagues. Can't see your code very
clearly. Is the stream quality bad?
Our RLC was generally generally good.
Uh, let me go find it.
Oh, yeah. I literally People have asked
me a million times about this because
what? Why is this thing broken?
Oh, that's bad. Yeah, this is not
supposed to be broken when I'm live.
I'll have to fix that. Let me go check
YouTube.
Stream quality looks fine, right?
Green just isn't that okay. Still
waiting for the reviews.
of the props.
Wait, what do you mean still waiting for
the reviews of the props?
Oh, like feedback from professors in
attendance?
No, I chatted with um
Eugene, Kathy, and Julian while I was
there. Anyone else? You deep mind
people? I don't think any other
professors.
actually. How the heck are you supposed
to train this thing with an RNN state?
just a concept for episodic memory.
Yeah, but it messes it messes with a few
things
because you can't do you can't Well, I
guess it's fine because I already have
Puffer Lib set up for this, but you
can't like sample batches of
transitions, right?
You have to sample segments. But then
the question is when you roll out
segments, how we treat Z.
I think the easiest thing here
Oh, wait.
I guess right now I literally don't have
it dependent on
Yeah, I literally don't have uh have it
dependent at all
on the hidden state.
The encoder is not dependent but then
the dynamics will be dependent right
because you have to predict
I think the easiest way to do this is to
just go through it twice, right?
At least initially.
That help
We don't care about the logit value. In
fact,
Z comes from logits.
Wait, how does Z come from logit? Z is
the encoding of the observations, right?
The action comes from the logits, right?
Z comes from the prior. What do you mean
Z comes from the
This is the thing that I didn't
understand in the dreamer paper that
just like made no bloody sense.
I mean, of course it doesn't. Paper that
gave me a ton of trouble makes no
Z is a function of
um
they're calling it a function of
H and X which I think that they're
indexing is screwy here, right?
Evolution of deterministic state. I
don't understand what you're saying with
that
like this part I understand right I
so this is
in Z should be encoding of observations
this is previous state and this is
previous action and then this gets you
next hidden
um you should be able to omit H from
basically
all of these I I think
the encoder should be able to operate on
X. I want to try out Dreamer V3. Is it
worth it? Um,
it's more so that I've gone through most
of the other options. Like I've gone
through a bunch of off-paul literature.
I've done I've implemented a whole bunch
of different things and this is kind of
what we're left with as potentially
good. The problem with dreamer and
adjacent papers is that the result uh
listed is very good. Uh the science is
horrible. Like this should have never
been published, let alone in nature.
Half the paper is provably wrong. And uh
the code associated with it is
complicated and also terribly written.
So there's a result that I mean I don't
think they made up the result. I think
they actually got the result. But then
the question of like how brittle is it?
How fiddly is it? You know, is this
actually something that you can
practically get working on a ton of
problems um without doing graduate
student descent is yet to be seen.
Yeah, I I probably don't fully
understand
this piece. I suppose I don't fully
understand like is the encoder supposed
to come before or after the sequence
model.
D comes from the logits of the RNN's
output.
Logit should be hidden state. No,
this isn't logits. This is hidden state.
It doesn't make sense to me though. Such
a like how the heck can
then it's not set up correctly like an
encoder right you need an encoder on the
observations
sampling yes when training oh I don't
understand that one bit
like there needs to be an encoder that
just takes the observations in and
sticks it into some latent And I for
whatever reason they have HT not even HT
minus one here. I don't understand this
architecture at all. Like these formulas
as they're written they just do not make
sense to me. They seem like they seem
circular.
The hat is sampling. Z is training.
Okay. But then why is this why is this
encoder set up like this? Right.
Why does this encoder take the hidden
state?
Yeah. Right. Okay, I understand that.
But like why why does this encoder take
hidden state then? Why doesn't it just
take X?
And for that matter, why do these take
hidden state instead of just Z
or just H? Actually, you just take H
here.
I don't know why they have these things
concatenated. It's like they're skipping
over the information. Like the RNN
encodes some information and then they
like go back and they grab the thing
from before the RNN.
encoder gets you a latent from the
observation conditioned on information
about the history.
Why the heck does it need information
about the history?
Like why does it need that?
I suppose I can probably modify it to be
like some something like that. It's the
way that they have the time indexing is
really screwy.
H is encoded from LSTM and OBS, right?
But like why? Because the LSTM already
takes the OBS, right? So why did they
put the OBS into the LS? Like why do
they put the obs into the LSTM and then
skip over it and like go grab the
original
to approximate dynamics transition
dynamics? Yeah, you don't need to do
that to approximate transition dynamics
though. They like they have extra stuff
in these uh they have extra stuff in
some of these networks that you don't
strictly need. And I don't understand
why cuz it's very screwy.
Oh, also like the difference I should be
clear on this. Um because they're using
a separate output from the RNN like they
also will technically end up making it
so that I would have to write a custom
kernel for this crap.
RNN doesn't need to take an observation
latence only. Yeah, but then the latent
are like look.
Okay. Yes. So RNN should should only
take latence, right? Right? So RNN
should only take latence because
obviously you need to be able to run
this in the imagined rollouts, right?
But then when I look at what Z is, I'm
expecting Z I'm expecting Z to depend on
HT minus one and they have HT here.
So like I it looks to me like this
component Z is defined to come after H.
It is right. So why the hell does the
encoder come after the sequence model?
Like they have this indexed in just like
a completely Byzantine weird way where I
can't tell what the hell they're
actually doing
HT minus one but they don't have Htus
one here like here let's here let me
just I'll draw it so that we can be very
clear about what I would expect this to
be. If you do it this way,
if you do it this way, in my head it
makes sense.
But this is not what they have, right?
So you take
H.
Of course, I have to do this with a
mouse.
I also don't like how they have
this is like weirdly as hell notated.
So, I'm going to do it in a way that
makes sense. you be
let's say that you give it HT minus
uh you can give it HT
Right.
original is like you suggest is it? I
thought that the formulas in there were
pretty much the same.
like something like this.
ZT depends on H
but HT depends on ZT minus one.
HT minus one.
The thing I don't understand is like you
expect this to work like in RNN, right?
you expect to like go
you expect to do like X goes to Z goes
to this right
but then somehow they're defining Z
after they're defining the encoding
after the RNN which doesn't make sense
to me
like the diagram doesn't help either.
Where is it? Yeah, this thing. How the
hell does this thing make any sense?
Like, first of all, I don't know what
these dashed arrows are.
This is also backwards.
Like, so this is like a completely
nonsense
RNN.
Where does first Z come from?
Uh in my head, first Z comes from
encoding of observation directly.
Like how is this an RNN, right? This is
H is producing obs and rewards.
Like they just have this drawn in some
completely Byzantine way that makes no
sense to me at all.
When you're planning there's no
observation. When you're planning there
is no observation, right? You're you're
acting on latence. So you should be
acting. The way that you do this, right,
is you don't need X to go in. You just
need Z and you can predict Z,
right? is you can take um you can take
like output of where is it? You take
like output of this is like ht minus one
uh action
minus one and you can predict zt right
that's how you would do it.
The thing is they have it like I'm sure
when I figure this out it's like I'm
going to just be mad because essentially
they have what are not that like they
have a few very short formulas but then
they have everything notated super
weirdly and I don't understand how the
hell any of this fits together cuz like
this is not how an RNN works. This is
backwards. So then the thing that's
built on the backwards thing doesn't
make any sense to me.
doesn't say that right
update Z. So h 0 is nothing.
And if this is the case
then Z
Q
uh Next.
Well,
E is discreet and H is
no that's a different reason, right? H
is the uh the recurrent cell state.
I'm pretty sure that's a different
reason uh antidote. It's
like H is the recurrent cell state
that's separate from Z, right?
What is that just saying? So have Z1
that comes from H0 and X0.
You need to update Z0.
Then you update H1 from
D
zero.
Time to ask Rock to put it in normal
language. Similar J. Well, what happens
when Grock gets it wrong and then I
spend the next three hours thinking I
understand but don't.
Literally, what happens every time you
touch an LLM?
Hang on. Maybe there's a way I can
understand this thing.
distribution. You don't even need a
distribution to make these formulas make
sense. Like that's separate.
That comes after this.
Now I understand the concept of encoding
into a latent so that you can then use
latent prediction to roll out forward
satcha. That's not the thing that's
bothering me is that the formulation
dependent on the recurrent cell state
seems circular.
H1
ends on
Yeah, it's just backwards. I Let me see.
I think it's
you have
H0.
Z0. There shouldn't be X0.
Why not? Z0 depends on H0 and X0, right?
The encoder has it right there in the
formula. Now,
how would you plan them?
Because the dynamics predictor, this is
this is this encoder, right? I didn't I
didn't write out the dynamics predictor.
The dynamics predictor would be like
uh you take this
and then you do
But I think in practice you do you don't
want to do um
you don't want to sample the first
observation right you use real data for
the first observation you imagine no
because otherwise it just has to sample
like a random initial state from uh like
a vector of zeros or from a random
initial vector, right? You would use the
first you'd give it like a seed state
and then it would hallucinate starting
from there. No,
because otherwise you also have to learn
the distribution over your training data
as well.
uses. Yeah. So, here's my question. Why
the hell do they do this?
Okay. Can somebody just explain to me
then here like this is what I want to
understand. If I were to write this out
like a sane person
in my head, you do like this. X0
one
two
not right arrows. because we all know
the direction. Uh and then this is
zero.
I would just train from here.
I just do like this
hat at right a you also get a out of
this right
need the action
you get Z2 Z1 hat
get like
two hat why would you not just do it
like
quantized version of the current state.
What do you mean quantized version?
Gan the dynamics prediction.
Why do you have to gan the dynamics
prediction?
What do you mean? RNN's regress to the
mean otherwise
is sampled from a discrete distribution
put out by
wouldn't regress to the mean. You're
predicting
you're grounding this versus actual
states.
Do you think Z came from H2 minus one
and Z hat came from HT?
Let me check.
If Z came
from HT minus one
and Z hat
um
Z hat would come from HT minus one as
well, wouldn't it?
And A. Well, but A is already included.
Well, hang on. It depends how you write
the syntax.
No, see it's the whole thing is screwy
because this should come from ZT, not ZT
minus one.
So H
hat should come from ZT.
They have this extra dependence, right?
You see that they're doing this like
extra thing and I don't understand Why?
need sampling to keep things coherent
probably. Has anybody actually tried
this? Like why do all these papers use
sampling?
You could imagine you can like you can
write down a deterministic form of this
where none of these are just these are
all just standard layers with no
sampling, right?
This is how it is though. At least we
figured out I think what this thing does
somewhat.
I happen to remember when VAE were ne
relatively new and they definitely were
not powerful. They were cool and
incredibly fiddly.
Heck, you could say that of RL up until
uh up until the puffer.
RNN's are hard to train and average too
much,
but that's just not true.
Like,
this is all just nerd snipe. Look,
this is a [ __ ] one layer RNN. Okay,
this is a one layer RNN beating Dota.
This like smokes every other single
result in the field by a mile. At least
in my view.
Like all this hierarchical stuff has way
way way way less evidence behind it than
just this.
Like most of the hierarchical stuff is
just people getting clever ideas that
don't actually work.
Yeah, I don't know why the hell it's
like this, but we will implement that to
see
in some sense. When I've actually
written it out reasonably, it's not that
hard of an ablation to do, right? It's
just you give it the previous state or
you don't.
Okay. So, let me see what I was doing.
Right. So, then you have
Dreamer had a better diagram. Did they?
I thought they kind of just reused
everything.
Oh, yeah. I guess this is kind of close
to what we drew. They totally just
reused the same formulas. This diagram
is better, at least. All
actually. Does anybody know if like does
efficient zero if anybody looks at
efficient zero too?
They do this stuff.
This doesn't look like it, right?
This looks like it's a deterministic
model with search.
The third is some scaling and
improvements to the RL. Uh, the third is
just some scaling and a bunch of
improvements to the RL that are wrong.
So basically the whole deal and the
whole reason that that paper drove me
nuts, right, is what happened is they
introduced all these cool tricks that
they presented as if they're actually
good, but it's because they stuck them
on reinforce, right? So if they if you
literally use the worst RL algorithm in
existence, then anything that you tack
on to it is going to improve over
reinforce. like they just used an
incredibly weak baseline for I have no
idea what reason.
Efficient zero is deterministic.
Okay, Satcha. So in that case, right,
Efficient Zero V2 reportedly outperforms
Dreamer. Um
so like what's the deal then? Like the
only thing that I see is the same across
both of these is the use of a world
model.
It seems like you can make them work
well with search. You can make them well
work well with like weird sampling
approximations.
Something just opened in the background.
That was weird.
for stochcastic stuff. They have
sampling.
Hey, Ryan.
Yeah. Yeah. So, Ryan was the uh
co-author really did he did all the
experiments um on that followup that we
did to Dreamer.
This is good enough to train the world
model, right? And then we can do
separately. We can do the RL.
Hang on. Maybe it's easier to do it this
way.
Fishing for shadows. Just like [ __ ]
talking that paper. as do I.
Which if you remember when I started
that project with you, I think we were
both super excited about like this
awesome new piece of research and how it
was like this big thing for the field
where we really hadn't had, you know,
any major breakthroughs in a while and
then it came out sort of came out of
left field and it was just all [ __ ]
Why reinforce? That's the thing. It's a
major oversight.
Yeah. Exactly right. And the thing is
they presented it as if it was or as if
it were and it was like completely I
mean it's like blatant scientific
misconduct.
Like this is the type of thing that
you'd expect from like some random like
undergrad or like early grad student in
a random lab without good supervision,
right? Like that's if it did if that
were the context, they'd be like, "Oh,
okay, cool. That's fine." But yeah,
exactly. They did a lot of these like
cosmetic ablation studies that like
didn't do anything. And whole thing was
just dumb.
with an inefficient on policy algorithm.
But that's stupid because he spent half
of the paper coming up with all these
tricks that like literally if you just
used a reasonable baseline algorithm you
wouldn't need,
right?
Like basically instead of just using PO
with like a normal clipping and stuff
came up with all these tricks as if
these were like you know the mandate of
heaven how to make your stuff general
when it's literally you just have the
weakest baseline imaginable in a new
context.
It doesn't work with a weak baseline is
the thing. He basically replicated like
the stability of the enhancements of PO
just with like a bunch of random ass
tricks that actually underperform the
simpler things that are used in PO when
you go and ablate them.
That's why we don't like that paper
around here.
breakthrough and neat coming soon. I
will be very surprised
there is
problem with a lot of the genetic stuff
is just like you're betting against the
hardware.
Like if you want to make like a
massively inefficient algorithm uh
that's like very general actually work,
you have to do it in a way that takes
full advantage of the hardware, ideally
in ways that you can't even take
advantage of with modern nets.
I'm fine with like giving stuff cool
names. You have to have some fun, right?
I remember I had like the first
conference I went to was NIPS 2017
and DeepMind had this thing. They they
called it like the curiosity
architecture or whatever. And then there
was like some crusty old academic show
up and like you can't name things like
curiosity until we actually fully
understand Curiosity and what it is and
how to architect it, whatever. And the
guy's just like, dude, it's it's just
the name of the thing that we came up
with, you know, it's kind of what it
does and we think it's cool. It's just
like, ah, academics are old and boring.
I see.
[Music]
popping up PO.
Tired of reading the 50th all you need
paper.
Yeah, I mean it's the current
implementation we have of PO is very
good for what it is, right? The thing is
there's just really not any good way to
like take what we have and make it
sample efficient without making it
massively slow. Cuz see the problem is
like you actually can match some of the
offpaul algorithms with po in sample f
but you have to go to these stupidly
small batch sizes that are just
completely antagonistic to the hardware.
Right? Like there's just no way to make
batch size uh 32 PO sample efficient or
efficient on the hardware at all. That's
why like all of RL is just so bloody
slow.
And like the Jax people got the clever
idea of Vmapping over seeds, which is
like, okay, cool. You can run many
seeds, but your experiment is still
stupid and slow, right? Like you still
have to wait like it that doesn't make
you wait not several hours to solve
Breakout, right? Whereas with Puffer, we
can just run it and we solve Breakout
immediately.
Same thing with a lot of the other tasks
that you would think would take a while.
former wrong move.
Um,
the thing is that they're definitely
slow.
They're definitely slow. I don't know if
they're good. I do know that they're
slow.
Like, I don't really think has anybody
done good comparisons of
transformer-based architectures, like
actually good comparisons to recurrent
architectures for small model sizes.
I don't really think there are any
as far as I've seen.
isn't a thing like transformer
architect. Well, but you know, you get
what he means, right? like the just the
idea of swapping from a recurrentbased
architecture to an attentional
attention-based architecture.
The fundamental problem, right, is like
The recurrent architecture,
the recurrent architecture is like O of
one. The naive transformer architecture
is O of N squared. And then the linear
variants are O of N
inference basian brain. I have no idea.
I honestly have no idea.
Publish a cool thing and then I pay
attention basically, right? There too
many of these like random niche sub
areas for me to pay attention to.
space.
Oh yeah, this has four.
Yeah, I should probably actually read
this, right, Ryan?
I'm obviously not going to do it right
now.
I honestly wish I could just like pause
all the crap I have to do with the
business side. just do this for a few
months and come out with puffer, you
know, puffer four, puffer five, and just
like have the damn field solved already,
but I have to split my time a little
bit.
Thank you for that link, though. I
forgot about S4.
I wish I could just do the fun stuff.
No, dude, this is not the fun stuff. Let
me tell you, this is not fun. This is
like brutally difficult, obnoxious work
where I spend 10 hours straight and like
have zero results to show for it. Okay,
the fun stuff is like me making
everything super simple and fast and
like, you know, hacking on new problems
and stuff like that all the time.
What's this?
Recurrent reinforcement learning with me
memoroids.
Wait, what do you mean get wrecked? This
is literally the same author, dude. This
is also Chris Lou.
Is he still an open AI?
It probably go. He's probably an SF,
right? Probably could go find him, take
him to dinner, and be like, "Hey, what
if this [ __ ] actually works?
Uh he didn't join recently. He was there
at Nurups like however the heck long ago
All right.
Got to pay attention to some of Chris's
stuff. We will see.
I remember I gave Chris a ton of [ __ ] at
um at Nurups a couple years ago for
basically his whole thing was like you
know what about like how do we implement
all these M's and jacks and like what
about all these evolutionary style
things and I basically told him one it's
impossible to implement like
increasingly complex and interesting M's
and jacks because that's not how GPUs
work and two the evolutionary stuff is
interesting but you get stuck on like
how do I build interpretably complex
environments and keep scaling that side
of things. And at least, you know, Chris
has done way way better algorithmic side
work than I have, but I think on the
environment side stuff with neural MMO 3
and what I've done with Puffer, I think
that that's been shown to be right.
Associative scan operators not possible
in PyTorch.
Well, Ryan, if I implement it and it's
slow, but it's good, I'll write a
[ __ ] kernel, right? It's not possible
in this like makeup imagin imaginary
land where like you can't write new
kernels.
The other thing I hate about Jacks,
it like abstracts you away from like
write a [ __ ] colonel.
No, it could totally be impossible,
right? Like for instance, literally just
um something as simple in PyTorch as uh
what if I want to reset the LSTM state
on done? That's impossible to do with
PyTorch operations. You actually have to
do it. Um you'd have to write a kernel
to do that fast.
get mo decks, too.
Yeah. Satcha, the only way you're going
to mo Ryan is uh if you beat him to
million step per second net hack and
puffer. Go ahead. Open challenge.
Net hack perform. Exactly.
And if you want to do the same with me,
you have to both beat me to the puffer
algorithm and outdo my fitness regimen.
Ryan, I have not yet sold on the uh do
multiple hours of hard exercise per day
idea.
I wanted to organize uh you know the
Buff Puff gym meetup at RLC, but I
didn't end up having time to do that.
That would have been funny as hell,
though. I'm not built like you. Yo,
Ryan, like I'm not a genetically gifted
athlete, okay? I was like bottom of
everything uh sportsswise growing up.
It's literally just like just have to
put in effort.
The current routine is brutal though, I
will say, because I'm doing, you know, a
10k around the dish. I'm doing a whole
bunch of compound lifts uh on a really
aggressive cut right now.
So,
genetically gifted with motivation. That
was also learned.
Yeah, that was also learned.
curriculum and re recurrent Genma
not happening.
Let me let me figure out real quick guys
what the heck I was actually doing here
because before I forget and
distracted here.
Um
cuz I I did actually have something to
do on this
level. I'll get closer. More exercise
each year is good.
Honestly, like having your own basic
setup helps a lot because actually right
now the running is way harder than the
lifting routine. So right now without
really any dedicated warm-up. I'm doing
like I just have everything pre-weighted
in my garage. I do a set of bench, a set
of deadlifts, uh a set of skull
crushers, a set of dumbbell shoulder
presses,
uh what is it? set of easy bar curls,
uh, a set of weighted pull-ups, a set of
weighted crunches, and I think that's
it. So, like, well, just seven sets at
the moment,
and that's like decent. Like, that's
already like decent maintenance plus
scoring up a couple weak spots.
The running is way harder
at the moment. I'm literally just doing
that exact thing five days a week.
And the only thing that's like remotely
sketchy in there is the fact that I'm
doing like a set of five relatively
heavy deadlifts cold.
It's not even that heavy. I've got like
335 I think on the bar at the moment.
So, I'm doing that cold for five.
Um, definitely could go a little bit
heavier than that. Like, I could go a
little bit heavier than that, but I'm on
a cut, so it's like we just do that.
Honestly, I think the grip is the
hardest part of that.
I'm doing them without straps, just with
chalk.
and we do this exact same thing here
now, right? Let's
actually make sure I haven't broken
anything first.
Last thing on to-do list is a quick
demo, a file for syllabus, and I'm back
to net hack. Very good.
found my old code for fixing the stupid
termination.
That is good.
Yeah, let's just let's do that and just
have it work. That'd be nice.
[Music]
right. So, I need to do
this
stuff.
I definitely don't feel like I have the
same energy today as yesterday.
Going to research is just brutal.
going to say that we do Z
like this for now.
Okay,
this does
this is supposed to actually train
because this is not world model stuff
yet, right?
See?
Yeah. So, this actually does
uh
Yeah. Okay. This does train.
Note, we're using the predicted rewards
instead of the actual rewards.
Oh, no. Actually, we're not.
My bad.
This is predicted rewards and predicted
terminals instead of real rewards.
terminals.
This still works, right? still train
somewhat at least. Now
Log jets. This
sample your loets.
Okay. So, this still runs but probably
doesn't train, right?
We need to adopt uh adapt the
architecture and such. But it's like
something roughly like this.
We can always try the easier task,
right?
If like literally we can get it working
on cart pole.
Okay. But we need to do a few uh a few
changes I think.
Oh,
mostly we just need to check that like
actions and stuff are being passed.
Oh yeah, we don't have action in here.
Do we
Why do we not use the action that's
needed?
Hang on. Does this even make sense?
Yeah.
No, it does.
Well, I could easily make the dynamics
function just take the action, right?
Hidden action like this.
Galaxy of LMS.
Those are just words. Those don't that
doesn't mean anything.
All right, there you go. So that's
dynamics model.
There be a dynamics model.
Okay, so now it actually has the action.
So this is technically the minimum thing
that we should expect to potentially be
able to learn something.
And we fail
completely fail.
world model training.
get your losses and get your RL
and then loss terminal loss plus D loss.
now we can attempt to figure out what
the heck is wrong.
Does anybody know details of
uh
details of the dynamics training? You
supposed to do some stop grads or
something or do you just differentiate
the entire network
if the entire network.
So then I do have this vaguely set up
correctly, right? Like
you run your forward evaluation which is
going to get you
well that takes Z. The first Z comes
from
time step zero of uh the observations.
Then you run ford eval to get logits and
value.
you sample your logits,
the hidden state and the actions
dynamics.
I try to constrain this to be I could
try to constrain this to produce the
real the real trajectories.
But like what happens if I just do?
So can I just say hey we're going to
actually do
the real actions only
get the action through
wait but through the policy for the
world model. Don't differentiate that.
What do you mean don't differentiate
that?
You can't differentiate that. That's the
RL portion. Now,
Oh, it's not sampling actions correctly.
Okay, that'll do it.
We'll see if it even works afterward.
Is this
uh this is using the dynamics?
This is something right
of course. Let's see
all rewards
Of course, the actions is the main
thing. All action.
This
Yeah. So, this still trains.
And now the question, right,
is just the difference of
uh what happens when you do this?
Go off of the data.
Yeah. So like when you ground it so that
um
the world model is just essentially it
has to do these onestep
uh predictions. It's really easy for it.
only getting the first observation,
right?
Yeah. Literally, it's only getting the
first observation.
Okay. So that is at least
that is at least something
also look at predictors of the
planning right. Yeah. So what I did here
right is I can force it I can force it
to take the real actions. So you
hallucinate everything except that I
force you to take the real actions. And
then the way that you're training the
world model, right, the supervised loss,
you're training it directly on those
one-step differences. So that means that
the hallucinated trajectories are
constrained to take the same actions,
which means you can't get far off of the
data, right? And that actually like
under this setting it learns and then
under no changes other than
uh like not forcing the action it
doesn't Turn.
The paper forces the actions.
Yeah, it can't. Right.
Actions come from trajectories. Really?
But then you're not hallucinating um
you're not like hallucinating new
episodes,
right? You're only hallucinating like
the exact data that you were trained on.
Where did you get that? Actually, if you
can show me that that like that would be
a major major difference.
I'll have to like rethink a whole bunch
of things if that is the case.
See if you can find that real quick. I
got to grab a quick snack because I'm on
a cut, but not this much of a cut. This
is insane.
I'm going to try to find the thing that
um
just said
well I'm pretty sure in Dreamer you
don't force you don't force the actions
to come from the trajectory right
or Um, like you hallucinate full
rollouts, don't you?
citation from the paper
where
seeing if what happens if I only let it
have the last few steps.
getting it to be stable for 16 steps is
very hard.
This is for training the world model
though, not for the RL component. Right.
actions are sampled from the actor.
Yeah. So that's the thing that I was
that's the problem, right?
Little trains.
Okay.
Need the first action
equation three. Same paper.
Huh?
Something screwy there.
Yeah,
first action is needed for the RNN.
Is it?
because I just I just stuck the action
into the dynamics.
Okay, but like let's say if I just give
it the first action
that actually trains.
Yeah, I don't think our indexing is the
same, but whatever. Like it's also
possible it's literally just doing like
the on policy RL on the first two
actions cuz pole super easy
I say doesn't learn like you need to be
at least seven be uh
let's see a teacher force I forced Yes.
Interestingly, this also
doesn't seem to do much on the harder
problem of breakout.
Okay,
this works on
the most stable thing in the world.
Oh, is it
castic can't check it on one seed.
Well, it's not
the one that I have here is not yet.
This should be a simpler form. Satcha
like do you see what I've done with this
on a bunch but I I haven't added that
component. Do you see what I've done
with this? Like
I've basically told it that the imagined
trajectories have to match the real
trajectories because you have action
here
and the only thing it has to do
is figure out how to
Bootstrap the observations up because it
only gets the first observation.
Check if your latents are actually good.
Yeah. Well, I don't know how we check
that
Like technically I could put the
optimization step uh separate, right? So
I could do it so that you optimize
the latence first and then you try to do
RL on the policy.
I think you need two op do you need two
optimizers for that? No, you don't.
Right.
Uh
Look at what your model recovers. I
can't really do that because these are
not pixel environment. Sacha,
these are not pixel. LMS.
It's like so close to being um
something, but it's just not yet.
I mean, you have to be right. Right.
Like, it has to be
cuz if the latence were good, then this
would be the same as the original
problem, right?
World model and then RL. Well, right now
they're done jointly in a sense, right?
Like you compute all the world model
losses and you compute all the RL
losses. I could technically make it two
separate optimization steps if I wanted
to.
I could see if that does anything.
I think that will screw it up though a
little bit. Like
the optimizer is kind of conditioned to
have the gradients look the same.
Take a look at the what the world model
recovers if you just train it only for
some time.
take a look at what the world model
well that's the only thing that can be
wrong right is that it's not recovering
good latence
because otherwise then this would be
identical to our standard RL setup right
is look I'm forcing it to take the same
actions
right we know that the reward and
terminal predictions are good enough
and the only thing that can be different
here is that we swap actually you know
what we can actually we can do this
easily right because we can do MB obs
now that's a good idea here this is an
alternative way of I think checking the
same things
uh hang on board eval
let's just do like this Right.
This.
All right. So, this is just T. So, now
we're going to do this with our standard
OBS.
If this doesn't work, then there's a big
problem.
Oh.
Huh?
No, it does work. It just takes it a
second longer.
Okay. So, you see here,
Satcha, based on this, it is that the
latent are bad, right?
You'd agree there's no other explanation
because I've given it if I give it
access to the full embeddings,
it trains correctly.
or at least well enough.
Okay, let's try one other thing.
Does it can it can technically be the
horizon being screwy, right?
Let's see if I do eight horizon, does it
still learn anything?
If I do it 16 horizon. Whoops.
Does it learn anything?
Yeah. So like basically separate them,
right? To separate out the world model
step and the uh the RL step,
not just the coefficients, right?
Takes one step of RL. Yep. That'll be
the next thing I have to try.
Try one other thing. This is 16. Yeah.
So with 16, you can still learn a decent
breakout model. The 16 is the minimum
here. I comment uncomment this
to get above seven for this to be like
meaningful. I think.
So, let's try let's try it this other
way. Do I have to mess with my optimizer
now, though? Because
wait, what happens if I want to apply
different losses that share gradients?
Test with horizon one. It should learn
instantly.
Uh well, no, right? Because
if you test it with Horizon 1, then you
screw up other things.
Like you scrub J, you scrub credit
assignment, you scrub a lot of stuff,
different settings. Yeah. So, I probably
need to do that. Yeah.
I mean, I suppose I can. I'm kind of
just being lazy.
So iffy on this doing anything.
Like it's actually not easy to separate
this.
You don't need to treat world RL and the
world model as separate models.
Gradients don't
Right. But the dynamics goes the
dynamics model will backrop into the
rest of the model, right?
You need you need to treat RL as
separate models.
You need to treat
so that is like don't have the dynamics
back prop through the rest of the model.
Is that it?
Don't back prop through dynamics. Okay,
I will try that next.
Let's just do additional world model
training.
If you have stuff to link me that should
actually like work, go ahead.
help
kind of made everything slow.
Linked a GitHub yesterday.
Uh yeah, I should probably look at that.
Sorry, it's not for me.
What?
No, I I needed to look at that. Hang on.
I think I Yeah, I still have the tab
from yesterday. Let me try one last
thing here because I you you
also told me a different thing which I
should try
which is right here.
So of course like you said that you I
should detach the hidden
and this is supposed to work because we
have you get ground truth obs right now.
So this is expected to work.
Now
comment this Okay.
that just detaching the gradients
doesn't make a difference here
I mean, I guess I should just start
trying to match it more closely
rather than like sitting here having it
not working at all.
I mean the main thing is that Z is
supposed to be a latent like it's
supposed to be a distribution right?
Yeah. Like the main thing is that Z is
supposed to be
ever liked PieTorch?
I mean, Jax is just way worse is the
problem.
Too hot distribution.
Oh god. Freaking too hot. That was one
of the techniques that we tested, by the
way, that too hot absolutely doesn't do
anything.
Wait, so it's not like a normal? It's
just a categorical.
Place it with continuous Gaussian. And
that's it.
real. Don't write it at all. Next, CDC
Jax is just like this crazy thing that
has the worst aspects of like
dogmatically object-oriented and
dogmatically functional programming.
It's like a very opinionated way to do
things and its opinions suck.
PF1 V1 and Jax is quite similar. Well,
you're coming from an absolutely
horrible library, right?
Like at the very least, PyTorch is like
it's lightly objectoriented for the most
part
and you can like write normal sane mode.
What What sort of distribution is this
thing?
One hat categorical
I don't understand how these logets
Dark.
Like how is the distribution even work
on this? Is it like a whole bunch of
categoricals
distributions one to one? Yeah, but I
don't understand what the hell it is
cuz look, they have this Z1 thing and it
looks to me like it's a whole bunch.
Like this looks like it's a 2D
representation. Now
that of categorical
Was
it one of them per OBS or is it a whole
bunch of them per obs?
Yeah, but like is it is it one?
It looks like it's a whole bunch per
observation or Now,
Right, right, right. No, I understand
what it is, but I Is it You're not doing
one categorical per observation, right?
It's like a whole bunch of them, isn't
it?
You're not representing the state as
like a single two hot, right? It's like
a whole bunch of them, isn't it?
the heck is that even remotely
necessary?
Hang on. I'm like, it's driving me kind
of crazy that this doesn't
We do this
continuous latency.
Okay, but like this is
why do you need sampling at all? Like
there's this is like a bandage patch on
like stochcastic environments or
whatever. Like this shouldn't be
relevant.
And it's slow as hell as well. Like I
know that's going to be as slow as hell.
Yeah, that should not be the thing
that's preventing us from getting above
random return though.
fact that they are like immediately
training on 16
16 length sequences
and completely destabilize everything.
Okay.
Yes, it is a
Okay, I see why it's fiddly now. Fine.
I can work with this.
Yeah, I can work with this.
So this is
eight steps of
uh the real data
and the eight steps generated.
Yeah, this is the tricky thing I think
is that it's going to go super far off
the data
um if you try to train too early
with too long of a generation sequence
length.
It's not just a training ratio balance,
I don't think. I mean, you can
technically do it that way as well.
I was going to do it a different way. I
was going to just do Hang on. Let me
just get this right.
So it starts out on real data and then
it goes to imaginated imaginated
imagined data.
Hey bet.
I can tell right away how your day has
been.
Just a bunch of tiring exercise. Bet.
It actually destabilizes towards the
end.
It's like trying to predict out too far,
which is interesting.
Got to go in 10 unfortunately. Thank you
very much.
Seen Daniel
Arthur and Dan boat.
Yeah. So the problem is then this
becomes
The whole point is we want to not have
to have okay
But then this needs to be stable out to
like eight steps or whatever.
Let me see if I can just do like a
balancing thing real quick.
KL balancing is important. You can't
even do KL
uh without having this be a
distribution.
XT given. Okay, so this is one we can't
do.
This is reward and continues. I see.
Well,
you know what? Let's just try Let's just
try some
try some.
Okay. So, this thing
doesn't trick right.
Very hard to get
Give us a better
world model.
We know it's purely the representation
as well, right? Like I just do this,
this learns, right?
What did I do
at all to learn
learn them joint, right?
Better learn anyways.
Super unstable, but it does work.
Okay,
this
This still work?
Did I just This still work?
Yes. Yes, this does still work, right? I
forgot.
Then
this is if we go off of the
off the path.
possibly.
Possibly what we have to do then
do loss
and we do world loss.
I mean, this should be such an easy
easy problem. No.
get all
the PR Add
your actions here.
This does train, right? That trains in.
Okay.
Still not super stable.
So,
we kind of have multiple multiple issues
going on here, right? There's a general
stability issue as well.
And again, this doesn't
do anything.
Let's go fix our
our general stability problems, right?
way we should fix our general
ability problems. Going to give you Z.
That's not good.
This should be a very easy problem.
have your prediction
boards and terminals.
We're going to do
just briefly
Okay, so this is tuned for
um a longer horizon
and we have our defaults
are indeed quite stable at the longer
horizon. All right.
This horizon eight
we have to do like this.
Who knows?
Interesting.
Well, I mean that does kind of cover one
thing here at least. But how does this
help us?
batch size should be like automatic,
right?
Like more stable
adjust our learn rate and stuff.
Okay. Like
this is a problem.
And now
now we can start ablations.
We replace this reward with the
predicted one.
still works.
Okay.
Predict we replace our observations
predicted obs.
Okay.
And now
not learn anything
learn not good.
Okay.
So we'll put this back to uh
learn the encoder correctly.
This is completely an encoder failure,
right?
This is now the learning of the world
model here, right?
Hatch
Better or worse,
Literally
just the actions are going to screw this
up, huh?
Don't give it any of the same actions.
It just breaks completely.
just go.
Then we give you your normal. This is
easy, right?
one perf good or 100 uh perf one for all
M's
eight.
It's just it's weird because like when
you give it
when you try to let it fully imagine its
own segments, I've not gotten a single
thing above random so far.
I mean, I guess that means I should look
for
problems with our model or
something.
table. No. So any like I can get the
world models to run but if I try to
train it on
the best thing that I've done so far is
get it to imagine its own like imagine
its own latence or whatever but you I've
still needed to keep it on the uh the
actions generated by the real policy. So
I haven't been able to get it to go
completely off yet.
first action carried
the latent
action. Yeah, but the thing is I'm
suspicious of this because like
I'm wondering if it's just like rlinging
the on paul data and then ignoring
everything else cuz cart pull's so easy.
It really it it shouldn't need any
actions from the real policy
date
of action. The action
state of action.
Does this actually use the state of
actions thing?
No, it's not used in the uh the LSTM in
this version.
Okay. So,
actions
This the right thing
Try on something more sparse. It barely
works on this.
We're not stress testing anything yet.
We're just trying to get the most
rudimentary simple as possible thing.
This should not be needed, right? Nor
should this
still run.
Not being used. Fine.
Encode.
Encode the obs.
Run forward on it.
Forward.
Oh yeah, because that just produces
logits and values, right? We just care
about the state essentially.
Um,
and this gives us what policy
policy dynamics on the state
hidden
takes the given action.
Fine. And then it gives you
you predicting
Should
this not be should this prediction not
be aligned?
How do I store the rewards? I think I
have this wrong.
stations. No, the reward goes to the
first
Wait, terminals.
This is wrong.
There's something I'm missing like
fundamental here.
log prop. Oh, wait.
There is
there is something I'm missing here.
crap. Yeah, there's a whole bunch of
stuff. Okay, I think I see it.
Yeah, this is going to be tricky
business, I think.
So the uh the thing I realized right is
that we have all this clipping stuff
to keep you on policy.
it. Okay. Well, I think I see what I can
do.
advantage. Still
still do advantage, right?
Not with the full
imagine data
what you need, right?
This is going to be kind of screwy.
uh, I'm going to try to get a version
of this.
I'm gonna try to get a version of this
where I like strip down some of the like
the offpaul correction stuff and puffer.
maybe I can just do it here.
It'll be simpler if I can.
Think I can break this
up here.
Not like I'm going to be able to just
do this, have it suddenly work, even
though it theoretically should.
Got me excited there for a second with
the 24.
What?
This close.
It's unstable, but it's close.
don't need this.
It's all fine
here.
Oh, wait. You've been completely
flipping have affected the IIL you were
doing the other day. Uh I think I when I
was doing IIL I fully rewrote the
losses.
The problem here is that you I kept the
RL loss.
not magically working yet as you can see
as Well,
this is the defaults. Yeah.
Trains instantly.
Just want to do it this way. Then it's
indexing.
Get rid of prioritization
completely.
Two
ditch
zeros
crap.
This is the full on policy version.
We can see it actually doesn't work out
of the box.
Oh, hang on. There's a there's another
bit.
At least we have like a pro uh pro
plausible plausible
pause
working.
Interestingly, it's very difficult
actually to get um even fully on policy
a version of this to work.
Like what the heck?
The heck, man.
supposed to work.
It's kind of crazy how as soon as you do
anything that's not what puffer lip
does, nothing works. But as soon as you
do puffer lip, it works.
kind of awkward, right?
Uh
So, what is it if you don't have a ratio
here?
It's tough cuz like I have this entire
thing optimized for uh
like the way that I would do this
with all the clipping. thing.
I just try this again and be more
careful.
I don't think it's just about being
careful, though. I think that it's
like completely set up differently,
right?
Okay, this actually does work without
clipping decently.
Okay.
Not clipping value loss apparently is
just
horrendous
this is not world model though. This is
me. I have to do this in order to make
that stuff work.
Because I think the thing that happens
is the world model,
the world model shifts you to be fully
fully on policy.
And like the way that I have it set up,
it'll try to clip the world model
updates in a way that doesn't make
sense.
Okay, so this still works, right?
Just have new log prop, no ratio.
Test
it.
And then for this to be
like remotely justified
um we should just have this stable
though. So, it's kind of weird that it
doesn't.
Maybe it's just doing ridiculous
updates. Let's see.
It could be a little more stable, but
it's
So, the reason that I did this
was that so we have a better starting
point for the world model work because
now we no longer have to worry about
clipping and things messing us not
messing us up.
I should do one other thing which I
should do.
Let's do BPTT horizon= 16
and then let's do 2048 MS.
Okay. Faster, more stable. Perfect.
This is our uh this is our starting
point for our world model work I
believe.
of crazy though the extent to which like
tough to just pull things from here. So
much you have to change.
we need to port a whole bunch of the
policy crap
back over. But it's going to be shorter
than before, so it shouldn't be that
bad.
Time is it only? Yeah. Five. I got
another hour. Getting hungry.
This is the thing is like when I have my
schedule is a combination of hard
exercise and hard research. It's like
I've only got so much steam.
It's tough to do that with on cut with
long hours.
We're doing like
this is a decent pace for research
regardless of the results.
Like we're trying a good number of
things out per day.
We're gaining insight.
I think this is all I need to do, right?
Is I just take this crap.
It's not any different.
Thought I was typing in my pseudo
password.
Yoink.
Thank you very much for your
contributions to the puffer cluster.
Last I checked, like the random short I
made on Sunday had nearly a thousand
views already.
And YouTube is just like
a ridiculous way to get stuff
distributed.
And where is this?
The shorts don't monetize well actually
at all.
I'd make a short vid going over the emp
shorts. Yeah, I should probably do.
As you can see, I've been like doing all
this research.
uh we have now retrofitted
our world model code
to this and we need to add the losses I
believe.
Got your policy gradient loss. You got
all these losses.
But we also need the other loss
drives me crazy. There's just like no
like there's just zero signal whatsoever
on this, right?
I mean I suppose if it's like on policy
anyways I can do this
do t
you can just do
Okay. So, that's useful information.
And then this one.
Not as well, but it still does learn.
Okay. And then it's when you do
when you don't give it an action,
Oh, wait. The reward model doesn't know
the action you took, right?
I calling the reward model on the right
thing. Isn't reward model supposed to be
trained on Z?
This doesn't work. What if I do
if I give it the action again? Does it
work?
Okay,
go look at the paper.
It's funny though. This was working even
before.
This was working even before.
So, what the heck could be wrong then
with this
dynamics
gives action, right?
It's state of hidden
state
policy for eval
It's so freaking close in some sense,
isn't it?
If it works with this line,
this little bit here uncommented, then
we have something to start with.
I mean this portion is now going off
policy
on policy with respect to the world
model. Right?
Think I missed
Make it make it more certain
and give it the easy mode.
Yeah. So, it's this is correct, but you
really really want the advantage. I see.
baseline
MB values under terms
ratio advantage. [ __ ]
Better. Right. This works. Yeah.
Good.
And
This bit.
Okay, that still actually does it. Right
now, this is the bit that doesn't work.
Leave.
Flip this over here so we can see it.
So, it's just you need the original
action some reason.
I've even gotten it to work with just
the first original action.
Oh, wait. What? What?
Hello. Is this it?
It was working there, wasn't it?
Is it inconsistent
or did I mess something up?
I'll run it a few times just to be sure
I didn't.
Oh, look. There it is. There it is.
That's better than random.
It's super inconsistent,
but that's that is something learning
through a world model.
There's no other channel through which
it could learn anything.
Like there's no other channel that I can
learn anything through.
It's definitely there. It's just very
very jank.
Yeah. Yeah. So to be clear, there's
literally no other way for it to be
learning now except for the world model.
So
There it is.
Okay. It's like super janky, but I'm
going to commit this for now so I don't
lose this.
Yes, bet. Because there's a reason for
it as well.
the clamping thing.
It's because the uh the world model is
on policy. It's because you're sampling
on policy with respect to the world
model, off policy with respect to the
environment like the original
environment policy and um the clamping
was being done with respect to that
original
We have a config engine. Oh, the no not
the reward clamping. The reward clamping
is totally fine. That whole argument is
stupid. You like you want reward
clamping there by default.
fix it in your environment. Your reward
should not be stupidly scaled.
Now, that one is like an obvious like
you're wrong. That's like an obvious
just have your rewards be sane.
The problem, you see, the thing is like
normally if you clamp rewards, the end
will at least do something. Um, and if
you don't, you'll totally screw stuff
with like bad reward norms.
So, we just do it by default.
It was a totally different clamping from
that one.
This was like policy. Um, this was like
the onaul offpaul clamp.
Totally different.
I want to make sure I didn't break the
fundamentals. And then I have one more
thing to try today.
You should have a bet bot in the Twitch
chat. Why would I do that? I already
have a bet.
bot support.
And one of the funniest bot things I saw
recently is somebody made a
somebody made a League of Legends coach
bot that just flames you the entire
game.
[Laughter]
want to get gotta get like a bot that
just flames like uh what is it? Rust
questions. Uh Jack's questions.
Um what what are the other common like
piss me off questions?
Oh, LLM questions, ironically enough.
Yeah, programming language.
Why not C++? That one's like actually
like a understandable question.
Is that not any league game with all
chat on? Look, I do play with that off
when I do play, but let me just say like
compared to compared to your typical MMO
chat, like League is the nicest group of
individuals you'll ever meet.
So,
I am uh very well used to
that.
Everyone knows C++ is bloy. Yeah, but
the thing is be people don't realize you
can actually get stuff done in C.
It's like most way more people have
spent decent time in C++ than in C. Like
most people like they take their systems
courses in C and then they go, "Oh yeah,
you don't actually build anything in C."
And they move on.
They don't realize like actually you
just don't need all those other
libraries. And most of the time they're
just in your way.
I'm trying to think how we make this
way. How do we make this
more consist?
I need to at least see it optimize once
made changes.
All the things I'm pretty sure are
illegal now.
Not illegal in the United States. We
have free speech.
You can be as toxic as you want on the
internet.
You will get banned, but you will not
get arrested.
I I don't know if this is just me
getting unlucky because I shouldn't have
changed the code in any way that would
mess with perf
at all.
There you go. Okay, good. Now I know I
didn't break it. See,
could be a bet.
But uh this is also a super easy
freaking problem.
That doesn't make it instantly work, now
does it?
No, actually what happens is that uh the
the the uh the he the uh universe is
going to like explode or whatever and
and the puffer just like eats all the uh
extra I don't know cosmic background
radiation string theory whatever.
[Laughter]
You know, if Puffer makes a trillion
dollars, you I won't tell anyone, but
there will be signs, you know, like uh
there might be a flotilla of puffer
blimps, for instance, that are like
shaped like the puffer. I don't know.
frankly, I'd way rather not get
acquired. But I'd way I'd way rather we
just like build really good RL that is
useful and then companies want larger
and larger contracts and then I simply
continue to fund science and research
for a long time.
Okay. So, when you give it the obs and
stuff,
it obviously works way better.
the encoder
I mean the uh was
it's like just drifting I suppose. This
Just the Z.
We should probably play with Z uh
distributional, right?
Honestly, stuff you can do personally
caps out way before then. The only the
only cool stuff you can do with more
money at that point is just like cool
companies and science and [ __ ]
Assuming you're not like a pathetically
shallow human
What's the paper reference saying? It's
Dreamer V3, but be careful because half
the paper's wrong.
This needs to be changed quite a bit, I
think. Well, we can try distributional
stuff tomorrow.
I mean, the good news, bet is that uh
it turns out a lot of stuff you can do
to make more money ends up being
economically productive,
but I don't it's definitely not
optimal.
I was way better off when the people who
end up making a lot of money happen to
get their kicks out of, you know, trying
to make cool science work rather than
trying to make the next luxury whatever
thing.
All right.
We'll have to try all sorts of stuff
with this tomorrow. I'm sure
like the vanilla version of this is not
like a clearcut. Oh, it just works
though.
The lack of a um a full reconstruction
loss might end up hurting us quite a
bit.
Come on.
My result so I can go get dinner.
Wouldn't it be kind of weird if this
thing like only works with um
stochcastic transitions
or made a stocasticity in the net be
weird, right?
I mean I guess we could try the simpler
thing would be
uh like the VAE type
formulation
just like some sort of distribution.
It's like literally works one and 10
times though. It's crazy.
puzzles on 64.
Uh, should not be that big.
And make sure the coms are like
reasonable sizes though.
Go look up like chess architecture or
whatever from uh any of the papers.
It's crazy. This like works, but you
would never know that it works if you
don't run it a bajillion times.
predictor thing could be a problem I
suppose.
It's like I'm sitting here like, "Oh,
did I break it?" But no, I know I
didn't. I know it's just this fiddly.
Yeah, there you go. See.
All right, we'll try to make this more
robust tomorrow. I think
for the folks who have been watching me
all day, thank you for tuning in. If
you're interested in my work generally,
you want to help with reinforcement
learning, pushing the field forward,
everything's on puffer.ai,
try the repo. It's free. Helps me out a
ton. Discord is where all the research
happens. So, just join here to get
involved. Really doesn't require as much
of a background as you might expect to
contribute um productively. We've
literally had new programmers spin up in
a few months. And uh other than that,
follow me on X for more RL content.
Thank you. And I will be back